Republic Services in their Hardball
collection tactics have been making the
trash company big bucks now last night
the 8 news now invest ORS told you how
they've been taking homeowners to court
filing liens on their homes and even
threatening foreclosure tonight eight
news now investigator Kyle Payne shows
us those collection tactics seem to be
working well
the lawsuits we're talking about were
for delinquent balances as low as one or
two thousand dollars Republic Services
The Exclusive garbage collector in Clark
County using those lawsuits as a
collection tactic taking some 500 Las
Vegas homeowners to court in the last
year or so and for Republic it seems to
be paying off
big trucks
collecting big bucks for the trash
company the public service's most recent
financial report released last month
shows Republic is hauling it in their
revenue from the fourth quarter last
year Rose 19.5 percent over the same
period in 2021 increasing from 2.95
billion to over three and a half billion
dollars
and the harsh collection tactics used by
this Goliath of garbage appear to be
working I think Republic Services is
pretty powerful powerful as a plaintiff
in the Clark County Courts Republicans
suing Rebecca Gandara of Henderson at
the eighth Judicial District Court for
over ten thousand dollars in delinquent
trash bills I pay all my bills for all
these years or so she thought but
Republic wants every last penny of the
10 grand it says she owes not including
legal fees and costs it's money she says
she didn't even know she owed and that
Republic hasn't proven she does and in
my eyes all the evidence is in my favor
but for now the collections process
seems to be favoring Republic part of
their overall increased Revenue includes
a jump of 400 million dollars from 2021
to 2022 a 12.6 percent increase up to
2.4 billion dollars and it's an increase
that offends legal aid of Southern
Nevada consumer rights attorney Peter
Aldis they are unnecessarily threatening
homeownership
and threatening homeowners we got a
rather lengthy statement from Republic
which boiled down to a no comment and I
had a very brief phone conversation with
Republic's lawyers in Las Vegas who
reminded me that Republic still has a
duty to collect the trash no matter how
much a homeowner owes still they're the
only utility company in the state that
can actually threaten to take your home
if you owe the money